on the mound tonight for the pittsburgh
pirates
rookie 23 year old right-hander miguel
yahoo rain is making a second
start of his big league career uh it's
pretty well on his last retired the
11 of the first 13 batters but then ran
in some trouble in the fifth inning
mike talkman will stand in got in on his
hands popped it up
third base way defoe is there and in
foul ground
he makes a catch for the first out
there's that cutter mike yostremski they
hit her now swinging a miss
and he strikes out yastremski the throw
to first completes it
that's the second out and buster posey
will bat with the bases empty
swinging soft lighter out to left into
that sunfield tom is there to squeeze it
and the giants are gone in order one two
three on the bump for the giants tonight
kevin gausman their ace going his eighth
start of the season he's 3-0 with a
1-9-7
45 and two-thirds innings pitched more
than a strike got an inning only 12
walks left these righties
as you can see very very difficult to
hit no matter
what side of the plate that you're
hitting from adam frazier swings at the
first pitch from gausman and pops it up
shallow left field crawford going back
from short underneath it and he makes a
catch
i think guzman will take that one pitch
one out the shortstop kevin newman
here's a swing and a chopper to short
crawford's got it he'll throw to first
in plenty of time to get newman who does
have pretty good speed
that is out number two two down for
brian
reynolds reynolds pulls one sharply but
right to first belt playing behind the
bag has it he's gonna race to first base
and he'll get there ahead of reynolds
gaussman retires the side in order
brandon belt will start it off
for san francisco that one is down and
in ball four
so belt draws the walk that's the first
base runner for the giants in this game
avalonia comes up now strike three call
and tom hallian i'm just my favorite
with that demonstrative strike three
looking call so the veteran is out one
away
brandon crawford crawford swings and
hits it right to the second baseman
frazier on the short one
relay two a double play at four
six three double play ends the inning
the cleanup hitter
will craig to leap things off guzman's
one-two pitch
is swung on and missed strike three
splitter got him
that's the first kevin gausman strikeout
here's a fastball strike three called on
the outside corner
polanco disagreed but that is out number
two
two down back-to-back strikeouts 1-0
pitch
that one's popped up by kai tom six up
six down for
the pirates to start against guzman
wilmer flores leading off for the giants
in the third inning
czech swing and craig is going to try to
track that down
oh what a nice bobbling catch over the
shoulder
no reason to get fancy with it like he
did but he made a nice catch
here's duggar to strike three call right
on the outer edge his command is
really good yahoo two down and up comes
gosman it's a swing and a ball hit right
back up the middle into center field
base hit
kevin gausman has started to swing the
bat a little bit
it's a two out single for the pitcher
and who knows
maybe mike talkman can run into one and
that turns into something big for the
giants
swinging the liner got a guy there yeah
defoe right in position
and that ends the inning it'll be the
top of the order adam frazier
to face kevin gausman not up nine down
for guzman thus far
two one is lined into right in a base
hit first hit
for the pirates first base runner for
the pirates and now
the lead off man aboard in front of
newman lines that one duggar is going to
make a diving catch
nice play stephen duggar wow that guy
can play a center field huh
that was dead hit written all over it
off the bat and that'll bring up brian
reynolds
reynolds goes down swinging he actually
tipped a piece of it but posey held on
strike three gosling's fifth strikeout
of the game
struck him out with the splitter he
threw a great one there
so two more strikeouts for gausman well
i think we're all still waiting for
wilmer flores to get it going i mean
look at that batting average it's down
to 189.
swinging the base flores down on strikes
miguel yahuure
has given up one hit through five
scoreless
innings gregory polanco for the pirates
against kevin gausman who's been great
again
what else is new polanco grounds one
toward third and past
the drawn in longoria it trickles into
left field polanco going to second
throws off line he has a hustle double
how did that ball turn into a double the
shift taketh
and that might be the worst hit double
in the history of the game oh the first
runner in scoring position got him with
the splitter
just nasty that guy knows how to pitch
seven strikeouts
two two fastball struck him out right
into the mid of posey
two down oh two he got the splinter and
gosmen struck him out
too nasty bottom of the six kevin
gausman's been
great but so has the pirates pitching
ben gamel
strikes out swinging that's four
strikeouts in a row
and number 10 in the game one two in the
dirt with the splitter he went around
that's strike three
tom alliance says posey gets the put out
at first
and kevin gausman strikes out reynolds
for his 11th strikeout
brandon crawford for the giants in the
eighth inning giants still
have not had a runner at second base in
this game
a fastball is hit high in the air to
right field and pretty deep polanco is
back at the wall
it is gone
a home run for brandon crawford just
over that 21 foot high wall
and that's the first run of the game
it's one to nothing kevin gausman's
going to take his time
warming up for the bottom of the eighth
as he stays in the game
swung on and missed strike three and it
was a great splitter
for a career-high 12th strikeout for
kevin gausman
two down and it'll be troy stokes
who hits scrounded to the right side
belt playing way off the line has it
flips underhand style to gaussman
who races to the bag and gets there
ahead of stokes for
out number three eight beautiful innings
pitched by kevin gausman tonight bottom
of the ninth inning in pittsburgh
very exciting night for kevin gausman
let's see if he can finish it off
so a couple little bloops and the
pirates are set up here
in the ninth inning first and third and
still nobody out that's gonna do it for
kevin gausman
great outing by kevin jake mcgee will
come in to pitch
and try to get the giants through brian
reynolds the former giants minor leaguer
who's turned himself into the best
pirates player
is coming up here through the right side
base hit pirates have tied the game
brian reynolds ties the game with the
single to right
now the giants are 90 feet away from
taking a lead crawford at third one out
and austin slater's got a chance
hits this one a little bloop into right
field it's gonna get down for a hit
and that will put the giants ahead two
to one giants
adam frazier three hits and four at bats
stands in against berger swinging a fly
ball out to right
toward the wall and off oh off the glove
off the glove
falls down here comes perez he's in to
score
fraser's at third with nobody out a game
tying triple the fourth hit of the night
for adam frazier
two intentional walks bases loaded one
out polanco is oh for 19 against lefties
this year swinging a fly ball hit deeply
enough to center
this will score frazier and the pirates
walk off winners on the sacrifice
fly by gregory poloko